Activision Blizzard held a conference
call with investors review its most
recent quarterly earnings report allowed
to half the call consisted of the usual
QA portion during which the company's
executives were asked about the high
number of YouTube dislikes that call of
duty infinite Warfare's reveal trailer
has amassed I'm Dave and welcomes your
remastered news update if you haven't
been keeping an eye on it the trailer
for infinite warfare currently has more
than 370,000 dislikes or thumbs down on
YouTube roughly twice the number of
lights is received whether that's due to
the series continuing to be set in the
future as opposed to the modern-day
setting the helped popularize it or a
general dislike of the franchise from a
vocal group or even something else is
impossible to say whatever caused it
Activision found a way to make it sound
like a positive first of all you've got
to love the passion of gamers this is an
industry like no other and a fanbase
like no other and we love that our fans
treat this franchise like it's their own
and has such strong points of view about
it there just aren't many entertainment
franchises on earth it can generate the
kind of passion the call of duty can and
that's a good thing secondly of course
we know that there are people in our
community who are nostalgic for the
boots on the ground South gameplay and
that's why we made modern warfare
remastered but we also have millions of
people in our community who want to have
the new innovative experiences in the
game each year and infinite warfare
delivers that and the good news is this
year we found a way to deliver both in
one package while keeping our community
together Hirshberg went on to say that
other evidence chest dislikes aren't
evidence that sales for call of duty are
finally set to fall off a cliff this
year and while of course we see the
passionate opinions online we also look
at other measurements and the fact is
while it's very early pre-orders are off
to a very strong start using the reveal
trailer referred to are up and in fact
the number of likes per view on the
infinite warfare reveal trailer or also
the highest we've ever seen hirshberg
response isn't unique as a publicly
traded company Activision can't lie to
its investors but like any other company
it tries to spin negatives into
positives all the time it's just
uncommon that it's done quite so well
and with such a solid underlying point
call of duty isn't going anywhere
youtube dislikes or not so are you
excited by the new call of duty and the
remastered classic let us know in the
comments section below or you can find
me on Twitter at a regular Dave and for
all of your Call of Duty news stay tuned
to gamespot com
you